The SCP Foundation seeks out anomalies across
land, air, and sea, and they’ve encountered
just about everything.
From roller-coaster cars rocketing through
the midwestern skies, to world-destroying
horrors deep underground in alternate dimensions.
So, it’s no surprise to hear they’ve happened
upon something right out of an old sailor’s
ghostly tale: An actual, real-life ghost ship.
You can almost smell the salty sea air and
hear the eerie drone of a foghorn just thinking
about it.
But of course, with the SCP Foundation, it’s
never simple.
It’s never just a ghost ship, but something
more lurking beneath the surface of that chilly
sea.
Several years ago in Arcachon Bay, on the
southwest coast of France, something unusual
began to happen.
Between nautical twilight on one day and nautical
twilight on the next, a mysterious ship would
appear.
It was a 19th-century brig, with two square-rigged
masts.
It would materialize from nothing, simply
fading into existence and sailing around the
bay.
The first sighting was reported by an elderly
man in a fishing boat, who stated that, as
the ghostly ship drew closer to him, his own
vessel stopped responding to his control.
He jerked the wheel back and forth, attempting
to steer away from the brig, but the boat
would not respond to his direction.
Suddenly, as if yanked by an unseen force,
the fishing boat was pulled underwater all
at once.
The fisherman, luckily, was able to grab a
life preserver and free himself from the boat.
He floated alone for hours until he was spotted
by another passing boat.
He tried to tell them of the unusual ship
he had seen, and what had happened, but by
then the brig had disappeared.
The ship continued to appear on a regular
basis, every time staying within a kilometer
of its original manifestation point, always
at the same time of day.
Its effect on nearby ships and vessels was
consistent too, unfortunately for anyone who
happened to be in the water at the same time.
Wheels, pedals, and other methods of directional
movement would stop working, and the vessel
would be pulled underwater.
Most of the time, the people on board drowned.
After a pattern was established, and it became
clear that the ship was definitely anomalous,
the Foundation designated it SCP-5987.
A 3-kilometer radius was set up around the
ship, blocking off the sea and air traffic.
Unfortunately, this was not enough to prevent
people from entering the radius anyway.
As more and more civilians sighted the ship,
and the drownings became increasingly difficult
to cover up, the Foundation decided to attempt
to neutralize the ship.
A task force was approved to search the area
for anything that could be used to put the
apparition to an end.
As it turns out, sometimes the rules the old
ghost stories teach you are true: You need
to figure out the correct way to put an angry
ghost to rest.
On January 1, 2019, the SCPS Submarine Nephthys
was deployed in the bay, with Captain Doumer
at its helm.
The submarine approached SCP-5987, and as
it entered its area, the communication system
went down and the submarine was pulled underwater.
SCP Foundation Command attempted to re-establish
communication with the submarine, and after
several tries, was able to get through.
Captain Doumer reported that the submarine
was partially damaged from colliding with
the ocean floor, but was still safe and operational.
The communication system had come back online
once the submarine had reached the bottom,
and the pull of SCP-5967 had ceased.
The research team deliberated over what their
next step would be, but their decision was
made for them when SCP-5987 retreated further
from the submarine and raised a white flag
from its mainmast.
At this point, Nephthys was instructed to
proceed to the point where the brig had first
appeared.
The submarine reached the manifestation point,
where they spotted wooden and steel pieces
jutting out of the ocean floor.
Noting that this was clear evidence of a shipwreck,
Nephthys switched to search mode, to focus
further on the small wooden wreck.
Captain Doumer then deployed the diving team
to clear out the wreckage and inspect it for
anything significant.
Several skeletons were found, corroded by
the saltwater to varying degrees.
As spectrally significant remains do not decay
or corrode, according to Foundation research,
the skeletons were deemed unimportant to the
mission and left where they were found.
One of the divers, Agent Lacroix, found a
carved figurehead, resembling a siren or a
mermaid, beneath the hull.
Unlike every other part of the ship, the figurehead
was not damaged at all, completely untouched
by the elements.
It was collected and brought aboard the submarine,
to be taken back to the Foundation for further
study.
As the submarine returned to the surface,
and made its way back across the bay, the
chime of a bell rang out across the water.
As the sound faded from the air, SCP-5987
faded from view.
The next day, when nautical twilight rolled
around, the brig was nowhere to be seen.
Removing the figurehead, whatever its significance
was, had somehow tamed the ghostly ship.
But what was the ship?
Where did it come from?
What did the figurehead have to do with it
all?
The figurehead, designated SCP-5987-1, was
brought back to Foundation Area 34 and examined
by the Marine Studies Department.
After some time, they were able to trace its
origin.
SCP-5987-1 once sat on the front of the Duc
de Dantzig, a French privateer brig from the
early 19th century, though analysis of its
material indicates it was made 200 years before
the construction of the ship.
The figurehead has some unusual properties
that set it apart from the rest of the wreckage
found in the bay.
It is able to control all seafaring vessels
within a kilometer, sinking them or running
them aground.
It was on the Duc de Dantzig when it sank
in 1811 after being burned at sea.
This experience was extreme enough that it
created a spectral imprint on the location.
An old American Secure Containment Initiative
file provided additional insight into the
origins of SCP-5987, and the events leading
to its demise.
The file described Item 6789-AH, a humanoid
with possible ontokinetic properties, named
Francois Aregnaudeau.
He was a French corsair, Captain of the Duc
de Dantzig.
A bounty of 10 thousand francs was placed
on his head by a group known as the American
Secure Containment Initiative - a precursor
to the SCP Foundation from the 19th century
- with a bounty of an additional 100 francs
for each member of his crew.
According to the file, Aregnaudeau was believed
to be some sort of anomalous being.
This assumption was formed from observations
of the Captain physically controlling the
paths of other ships within his line of sight.
While standing on the bough of the Duc de
Dantzig, Aregnaudeau was able to manipulate
the riggings and sails of enemy ships in any
way he wanted.
Some of the ships were pulled underwater,
their crews drowned.
Others were dashed against rocks and destroyed.
Some others were run aground and looted.
This ability allowed the Captain to rise through
the ranks of the French military, capturing
over 20 military and merchant ships in less
than 10 years.
The Initiative planned to capture the Captain
when he disembarked his ship, and sink the
ship in order to prevent him from escaping
custody.
However, before they could implement their
plan, his own crew beat them to it.
While the exact details of what happened are
unknown, an 1812 report published in a French
newspaper described an encounter between a
navy ship and the Duc de Dantzig.
They spotted the ship floating at sea, bobbing
on the waves and heading in no particular
direction.
Concerned, the navy crew determined the best
course of action was to reach out to the crew
of the other ship and determine if they were
Frenchmen in need of assistance.
As the Navy ship drew closer, the crew was
perplexed and worried by a heavy silence that
hung over the other ship.
There was no noise coming from the deck, no
yells for help, no shouted orders.
Only the slap of the water on wood.
The ship did not appear to be damaged at all,
either.
There was no sign of cannon fire that might
have blown out a part of the ship, nor was
there any damage from a recent storm.
There was nothing that should have been keeping
the ship from continuing on its course.
The navy ship came up beside the Duc de Dantzig,
with a group of sailors preparing to board
it.
As they climbed aboard, they were horrified
at what they found.
The deck was positively drenched in blood,
smeared across its surface as if the entire
crew of at least 50 men had emptied their
veins right onto it.
As the navy men continued their search, the
source of the blood soon became entirely too
clear.
The ropes had been turned into makeshift nooses,
corpses hanging from them and swinging limply.
Some other bodies were strewn across the deck,
abdomens ripped open and their entrails yanked
out, thrown to the side.
Others had their faces collapsed by cannonballs,
even though there were no signs of enemy fire.
A closer look revealed that the blasts had
come from their own cannons, turned on themselves,
aimed at their own faces, and fired.
The Captain himself, reeking of death and
putrefaction, had been tied to the main mast.
Swords were stabbed through his hands and
his feet like a crucifixion.
The naval officers made their way to the hold,
where they found bloodied papers identifying
the ship.
They were uncertain what had happened, but
posited that the crew had gone mad while lost
at sea, turning on the captain and then each
other.
To be safe, they decided to set the ship on
fire and leave it there to sink to the bottom
of a watery grave.
With Captain Francois Aregnaudeau disposed
of, though not by them, the Initiative closed
their case file on him and the story was forgotten.
At least, it was until the 2019 mission to
investigate SCP-5987.
With the discovery of the figurehead from
the wreckage, a centuries-old mystery was
solved.
According to the researchers tasked with examining
the figurehead, it resented having to do the
work of war and destruction and disliked working
at the beck and call of the Duc de Dantzig
and its captain.
Somehow, it compelled the crew to destroy
each other and the captain, in an attempt
to free itself.
When the naval officers discovered the carnage
and set the ship ablaze, it was traumatic
enough that whatever supernatural force powers
the figurehead left a spectral disturbance
behind.
The designation SCP-5987 was then created.
SCP-5987-1 has been treated for saltwater
protection and attached to a historically
accurate miniature 19th-century sailing ship.
The ship, with the figurehead attached, is
kept in a saltwater enclosure in Area 34’s
Marine Observatory.
It is checked once a month for any signs of
damage or degradation.
The figurehead uses its ability to control
ships to sail its new home around the saltwater
enclosure.
It seems to enjoy spending its time this way,
and several of the officers assigned to guard
the enclosure have reported hearing voices
singing the French sea shanty Boney (Was a
Warrior).
When the guards opened the door to look for
the source of the voices, however, they could
not find a source.
Somehow, the figurehead is able to sing as
it sails around its miniature sea.
It’s not every day that an SCP has a happy
ending, but this seems to be one of those
rare cases.
The ghost ship sightings have ceased altogether,
the case has been closed, and the anomaly
is at rest.
It’s not hard to imagine that the figurehead
is enjoying its new, peaceful life, no longer
forced to sink ships or be used as a weapon
of war.
Instead, it can simply float, and sing its
songs.
Now go check out “SCP-1861 - The Crew of
the HMS Wintersheimer” and “A Sea Snail's
Fantasy SCP-1867 - A Gentleman” for more
horrors and oddities of the high seas!